bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
sur public sénat à suivre cet après-midi
sur notre antenne à l'examen en séance
publique par les sénateurs de la
proposition de résolution présentée par
le groupe communiste qui demande la
reconnaissance de la manifestation du 17
octobre 1961 manifestation qui s'était
tenue à paris et qui avait fait de
nombreuses victimes algériennes la
semaine dernière françois hollande dans
un communiqué a déclaré que la
république
reconnaissez avec lucidité ces faits
parlant même d'une répression sanglante
tollé à droite christian jacob le chef
de file des députés ump a jugé ces plots
ses propos intolérables expliquant qu'on
ne pouvait pas mettre en cause à la
police républicaine de l'époque
or faut-il le rappeler c'est maurice
papon qui était préfet de police en 1961
tout de suite donc direction l'hémicycle
du sénat poursuivre ce débat
bon après midi à tous l'ordre du jour
donc appel
l'examen de la proposition de résolution
tendant à la reconnaissance de la
répression d'une manifestation à paris
le 17 octobre 1961
présenté en application de l'article 34
1 de la constitution par madame eliane
assassi et les membres du groupe crc
dans le débat la parole est à monsieur
pierre laurent auteur de la proposition
de résolution
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues je me
réjouis de la discussion de cette
proposition de résolution que nicole
borvo cohen seat
au nom de notre groupe a déposé le 30
janvier 2012
cette résolution fait droit à une
demande portait depuis de longues années
pour que la france reconnaisse les faits
sanglants qui se sont déroulés le 17
octobre 1961
elle propose en outre la réalisation
d'un lieu du souvenir à la mémoire des
victimes
permettez moi de rendre hommage au
combat de nicole borvo cohen seat qui
aux côtés de mon ami guy fischer
intervenants tout à l'heure et en tant
que présidente de notre groupe et élue
parisienne s'était grandement impliqué
dans la reconnaissance des crimes
coloniaux dont justement le 17 octobre
1961 mais aussi d'autres comme la
disparition entre guillemets du
mathématicien maurice audin en défendant
cette proposition je veux d'abord dire
ma satisfaction de la très récente
expression du président de la république
qui vient de déclarer le 17 octobre
dernier je cite la république reconnaît
avec lucidité c'est fait
cinquante et un 51 ans après cette
tragédie
je rends hommage à la mémoire des
victimes c'est un acte important tant
attendu auquel il nous revient
aujourd'hui de donner toute sa portée
par un vote solennel de notre assemblée
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
d'être est parmi nous je pense que ce
débat aurait mérité la présence du
ministre de l'intérieur
je me réjouis que notre proposition de
résolution permettent la reconnaissance
de ces de ces faits sanglants
elle doit être cette proposition de
résolution un engagement à ce que ce
premier pas soit suivi des actes
nécessaires à l'établissement définitif
de la vérité et à la reconnaissance des
crimes coloniaux dont le 17 octobre 1961
constitue avec d'autres un épisode
tragique
nous pensons notamment que la
reconnaissance des faits par le
président de la république doit conduire
à l'ouverture
des archives et au delà à toutes les
archives concernant les guerres
coloniales et leur cortège de répression
et de massacres ne serait-il pas
souhaitable à ce sujet que les archives
de l'état soient soumises à des règles
communes en martyr en matière d'art
chiffre conforme au fonctionnement d'un
état démocratique
cela impliquerait que soient versés aux
archives nationales celles de la
préfecture de police de paris
des ministères de la défense et des
affaires étrangères quitte à ce que
leurs fonds relève bien évidemment de
dispositions particulières précise est
justifiée et que les archives des
anciens ministres premier ministre et
président de la république relatives à
leur fonction ne soit pas privatisée par
les intéressés mais versé dans leur
ensemble aux archives nationales
cela aurait aussi le mérite de
contribuer à faire la lumière sur des
agissements coloniaux de la france et de
son armée dans les pays africains
notamment la fin de rapports coloniaux
ou néo coloniaux avec ces pays souhaité
récemment par le président de la
république à dakar passe par là le
développement de nouvelles relations de
coopération aussi dans la même logique
il faudrait d'ailleurs que la notion d'
archives incommunicable entre guillemets
telle qu'elle apparaît dans la loi de
2008 soit abrogée pour être fidèles à
leur mission scientifique les historiens
ont besoin de pouvoir accéder librement
aux archives échapper aux contrôles des
pouvoirs ou des groupes de pression et
travailler ensemble
en l'occurrence avec leurs homologues
des deux rives de la méditerranée
la vérité devra aussi être dite sur
l'organisation criminelle dolores que
certains à droite au sein même de l'ump
sans même parler de l'extrême droite
continue aujourd'hui d'essayer de
réhabiliter ce qui s'est passé ce jour
du 17 octobre 1961 n'était pas un
événement isolé survenu en un lieu et en
un moment unique mettait le paroxysme
d'une politique de guerre coloniale
symbolisée par la mise en place du
préfet de police maurice papon est
couverte voire encouragée par les plus
hautes instances de l'état de l'époque
on a vu s'effectuer cette nuit là dans
les rues de la capitale
une chasse à l'homme aboutissant à des
assassinats et pour ce
c'est pour cela que je pense comme
beaucoup d'historiens que l'on peut
parler en est en l'espèce d'un crime
d'état d'un crime d'état emblématique
en effet certaines autres dates nous
rappelle à quel point la violence et le
crime d'état sont indissociables du
colonialisme
je pense à la sauvage répression du 8
mai 45 à sétif des massacres de
madagascar en 1947 de la terrible guerre
d'indochine et dans la totalité de la
guerre d'algérie dont la bataille
d'alger
la disparition du mathématicien maurice
audin en juin 57 lots massacre du 8
février au métro charonne qui sur tous
des épisodes particulièrement violent
mais revenons à la nomination de maurice
papon qui est un moment à mon avis à un
moment clé pour comprendre ce qui s'est
passé le 17 octobre 61 est symptomatique
de la mise en oeuvre de cette politique
coloniale en effet maurice papon au
passé de collaborateur bien connu et qui
jusqu'en mars 1958 était un préfet
régional de l'est algérien
réputé pour ses méthodes brutales
maurice papon devient le 16 mars 1958
préfet de police de paris
il le restera après le changement de
régime de mai 1958 pape on n'hésite pas
pendant cette période a organisé à
plusieurs reprises des rafles massives
sous son autorité les assassinats de
nord africains par les forces de risques
de répression s'accélère au cours de
l'été 1961 la pratique de jeter des
sommes assommés parfois ligoté dans la
seine est attestée dès septembre de
cette année le 2 octobre 1961 police
maurice papon préfet de police
n'avait-il pas déclaré pour un coup reçu
nous emporterons 10 ont ce même des bus
doit il veut imposer aux algériens
vivent en région parisienne un
couvre-feu
c'est dans ce contexte que le 17 octobre
1961 des dizaines de milliers
d'algériens majoritairement des ouvriers
manifestent pacifiquement contre cette
mesure
discriminatoire scandaleuse et illégale
pour certains c'était la première fois
qu'ils quittaient leur bidonville et
c'est dans ce contexte aussi que se
déroule que se déroulera quelques mois
plus tard sous la responsabilité du même
le massacre de charonne l'ampleur et la
gravité de la répression on peut être
masquée aux yeux de beaucoup la
signification politique de cette journée
qu'au coeur de la capitale qui se
prétendait encore officiellement
également celle de l'algérie la
quasi-totalité des algériens valide
soient descendus dans la rue malgré les
violences qui inévitablement les
attendait et le signe que plus personne
au sein de cette communauté ne voulait
de l'algérie française même transformé
même réformé lorsque les algériens pur
même quelques instants seulement ce
soir-là crier leur mot d'ordre
ce fut d algérie algérienne le fnl le
fln au pouvoir
libéré benbella même les plus hostiles
des observateurs convenait de la
détermination de la foule
alors ce fut le déchaînement les forces
de postes de police se précipitent sur
les manifestants avec une sauvagerie
inouïe de partout sorte les bidules ses
longues matraques meurtrière
les policiers frappent à tour de bras
ceux qui sont à terre sont
impitoyablement matraque et piétiné roué
de coups mâchoire brisée yeux exorbités
fracture ouverte
rien n'arrête la furia des coups de feu
sont tirés dans divers lieux à bezons au
pot saint-michel d homme ensanglanté
souvent à demi inconscient parfois
ligoté son basculer dans la seine
d'autres sont jetés pêle-mêle sans
ménagement dans des cars de police ou
les attentes de nouveaux matraqueurs une
véritable noria de cars seront vers les
dépôts les commissariats vite saturé des
bus de la ratp est même le palais des
sports sont réquisitionnés selon les
recherches actuelles qui maintenant
converse
il y aurait eu le 17 octobre deux sont
morts le 17 octobre 1961 200 morts
ce qui donne pour le moins une résonance
particulière aux propos de merris papou
que je citais tout à l'heure
sans parler des plus de onze mille
arrestations qui officiellement s'en
suivirent et des nombreux blessés
les crimes commis au 17 octobre 61 ont
suscité à l'époque un débat public et
une indignation dans les milieux
progressistes mais dès ce moment là le
pouvoir s'est acharné à étouffer la
réalité du crime et les responsabilités
il aura donc fallu cinquante et un ans
pour que le président de la république
reconnaisse pour qu'un président de la
république en l'occurrence françois
hollande reconnaissent les faits à
l'époque l'humanité le parti communiste
ces élus nationaux et parisiens
dénonceront avec d'autres comme simone
de beauvoir andré breton michel butor
aimé césaire marguerite duras claude roy
laurent schwarz hervé bourges et
beaucoup d'autres dénonceront
l'abomination qui vient de se produire
les communistes interpelle les autorités
dès les premiers jours qui suivent le
préfet de police de paris et par exemple
directement interpellé le 27 octobre
1961 au conseil de paris par l'élu
communiste raymond bossue je me permets
de citer ces propos combien y at il eu
deux morts parmi les algériens combien
de noyer combien de décès à la suite de
coups jour après jour heure après heure
afflux des témoignages d'algériens jetés
à la seine
disait il le 27 octobre 61 d'autres
informations nous sont parvenues
poursuivre at il des algériens ont été
tués par balle frappée à la matraque à
coups de pieds a rose est halal ans
étranglée
c'est une honte pour le gouvernement
gaulliste qui jusqu'à preuve du
contraire et bien l'ordonnateur des
actes racistes et criminelles de la
police et il conclu la vérité qui éclate
aux yeux de tous et que le peuple
algérien
ce peuple qui sait donner un
gouvernement le grp à ce peuple dans son
ensemble veut sa liberté dans
l'indépendance à l'époque le préfet de
police reste de marbre devant cette
interpellation et ne répond pas quant
aux dirigeants du parti communiste et
sénateurs jacques duclos
dans une question orale posée dans cet
hémicycle 19 octobre 1961 il dénoue
cette politique de répression brutale
rappelons par cm2 méthode une des
périodes les plus tragiques de notre
histoire nationale et ils dénoncent
également les compléments scandaleuses
les complaisants scandaleuse dont
bénéficie de la part du gouvernement les
factieux plastiqueurs et les criminels
de l'oas
pire encore dès les premières
contestations
le ministre de l'intérieur de l'époque
roger frey s'oppose à toute tentative d'
enquêtes notamment parlementaire
les témoignages recueillis des cdd ce
moment là par les éditions maspero sont
saisis chez les brochures et des revues
comme vérité liberté où les temps
modernes sont également saisis en 62 la
projection du film octobre à paris de
jacques panigel ces projections sont
interdites
le pouvoir en place puis les pouvoirs
qui succéderont organisons organiseront
autant que c'est possible et aussi
longtemps que c'est possible
l'oubli il faudra attendre la venue de
la gauche au pouvoir
vingt ans plus tard pour que le 17
octobre 61
le journaliste marcel trillât diffuse au
cours d'un journal télévisé du soir un
reportage à ce sujet effaceront jaillir
dans la mémoire collective ces
événements en 1984 c'est le romancier
didier da nang ce qui dans son livre
morte pour mémoire évoque ces événements
dont l'intrigué entrecroisent histoire
de la résistance et histoire du 17
octobre le 17 octobre 1991 il eu une
première manifestation d'ampleur dans le
cadre de la commémoration de ces
événements
enfin le 23 septembre 2001 le conseil de
paris vote
c'est le premier acte de reconnaissance
fort vote la pose d'une plaque
commémorative qui deviendra effective le
17 octobre de la même année la ville de
gennevilliers a elle aussi inaugurer une
place 17 octobre 61 le 19 février 2007
le 50e anniversaire de ce drame fut une
étape plus importante encore dans ce
parcours mémorielle la mobilisation
grandit et s'élargit alors
seuls les plus réactionnaires continue
de donner de la voix pour déclarer que
ces commémorations constitue une
provocation et qu'il n'est pas question
que la france présente ses excuses et
reconnaissent le crime
dans la même veine d'ailleurs le maire
de neuilly jean-christophe fromantin
pour refuse par exemple de s'associer à
cette époque à une cérémonie organisée
par les maires de nanterre argenteuil
asnières gennevilliers colombes et
d'autres villes pour rendre un hommage
aux victimes du massacre du 17 octobre
sur le pont de neuilly
pour la simple raison dit il à l'époque
je cite qu'il s'en tient au calendrier
des commémorations de l'état et que
neuilly n'a jamais été associé à ce
terrible événement par le passé même si
à l'instar de la fondation pour la
mémoire de la guerre d'algérie dotée de
moyens publics importants est sous la
coupe d'associations nostalgiques
nombreux sont ceux encore qui à droite
et alex et à l'extrême droite tente de
vente et les aspects positifs de la
colonisation
l'idée d'une liberté d'accès aux
archives pour tous fait de plus en plus
son chemin
néanmoins il faut noter que les forces
de la réaction non pas tout à fait
renoncé encore à leur travail de déni de
l'histoire
c'est évidemment le cas du front
national dont les représentants étaient
et sont toujours à la pointe de
l'abjection
sur ce sujet comme sur bien sûr bien
d'autres mais il faut aussi noter des
propos extrêmement navrant venue des
rangs de la droite
quand par exemple le chef de file des
députés ump christian jacob estime à
propos des déclarations françois
hollande sur la répression sanglante du
17 octobre qu'il est je cite intolérable
de mettre en cause la police
républicaine et avait et avec elle la
république toute entière
en cela il se situe dans la droite ligne
des propos qui n'ont jamais cessé pour
essayer de minimiser la responsabilité
du pouvoir de l'époque dans ces
événements par exemple d'un bernard l'a
fait pilier s'il en fût de la mouvance
d'algérie française qui le 31 octobre
1961 déclaré il n'est pas imaginable que
le
fait de police dont on connaît le
respect des principes démocratiques où
seulement du droit naturel et pu décider
sans motif grave des mesures
discriminatoires privant une partie de
la population de l'exercice de ces
libertés individuelles protectrice de la
population parisienne est aussi depuis
des années au risque de sa vie des
travailleurs musulmans terrorisé par le
fln notre police est qu'elle mérite et
qu'elle conserve l'estiment de ce
qu'elle défend le peuple le vrai peuple
de paris a compris que son dévouement a
su éviter que les incidents aujourd'hui
évoqués ne dégénère entre contrat j'ai
dit voilà ce qu'il déclarait le 31
octobre 61 dans l'odieux on peut encore
citer les déclarations d'alex moscovitch
conseiller municipal eu les nerfs de
paris qui le 27 octobre 61 pour défendre
une motion de confiance au préfet de
police papou prononça il faut le savoir
les paroles suivantes
je cite tous ces agents de l'ennemi
doivent être envoyés du territoire
métropolitain
voilà deux ans que nous le demandons ce
qu'il faut l'autorisation est
suffisamment de bateaux
le problème qui consiste à faire couler
ces bateaux ne relève pas hélas du
conseil municipal de paris fin de
citation et la motion qu'il défend des
était à l'époque adopté par la majorité
de droite par 47 voix contre 30
le temps est venu oui le temps est venu
51 après et il est même grand temps est
bien tard pour en finir avec ces propos
infâmes
à rebours de l'histoire en reconnaissant
le crime en faisant la clarté sur les
responsabilités en ouvrant les archives
en votant cette proposition de
résolution
nous contribuerons à la dignité de la
république nous appellerons la douleur
de toutes les victimes civiles et
militaires de celle de la de celle de
leur famille pour redéfinir
enfin des relations saines avec le
peuple et le gouvernement algérien
la prise en compte de ce passé
participera à l'effort nécessaire
de la reconstruction d'une coopération
réciproquement avantageuse entre la
france et l'algérie tant sur le plan
culturel et économique et scientifique
intégrant la question de la libre
circulation des personnes qui ont très
fréquemment des attaches familiales dans
les deux pays
l'adoption de cette proposition de
résolution va en ce sens et c'est
pourquoi je vous demande et je vous
propose de la voter merci merci
dans la suite du des balles la parole
est à monsieur roger karoutchi
prochain
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues réécrire
l'histoire n'en fait pas la vérité
historique et je dois dire que je suis
un peu un peu mal à l'aise devant le
texte qui est proposé mal à l'aise non
écoutez d'abord mal à l'aise parce que
moi je comme d'autres je finis au maroc
revenu en métropole après et je n'ai
jamais eu ni de réaction ni de
sentiments négatifs à l'égard du pays
d'où je venais mal à l'aise parce que il
faut pas dans l'histoire 30 ce qui
arrange et laisser de côté ce qui ennuie
il faut tout prendre vous parlez de 1961
pardon de vous dire parce que selon vous
vous dites oui d'ailleurs le
gouvernement gaulliste qui étaient
dénoncés qui d'ailleurs a peut-être même
couvert certains des agissements de
l'oas sincèrement pardon de faire
remarquer gentiment que les tentatives
d'assassinât c'était plutôt par le res
l'assassinât du général de gaulle pas
franchement l'assassinât des autres et
donc de ce côté là un peu de calme quand
même sur le renvoi de la responsabilité
par rapport à l'eau as low as a essayé
d'assassiner à plusieurs reprises le
général de gaulle je n'ai pas souvenir
de leur s est essayé d'assassiner
jacques duclos
alors qu'est-ce que qu'est ce qu'on fait
ce qu'on dit en vrai en 1961
sais tu pas soufflot nommé reprenez les
documents d'époque à paris et depuis
la guerre d'algérie a impliqué des
communautés du côté du fln
du côté de l' os du côté encore de ce
qu'était le mouvement national algérien
de messali hadj des 1000 morts des 1000
morts c'est le chiffre reconnu de la
lutte interne entre le mouvement
national algérien et le fln 10000 morts
dix mille morts en algérie comme à paris
comme en allemagne
je n'ai interrompu personne merci de ne
pas m'interrompre savais pas ce que j'ai
entendu j'ai de la marge je mets les six
voix parlée respecter un peu la parole
des autres même si la vôtre est
naturellement imminente des 1000 meurent
à paris puisque parle de paris à paris
les commissariats de police
depuis 1959 sont protégées par des sacs
de sable à paris où le général de gaulle
a entamé le procédé la procédure qui va
conduire à l'indépendance de l'algérie
non sans mal même à l'intérieur de la
droite
même à l'intérieur de son temps c'est
son courage et son génie politique
d'avoir dit imposé qu'il fallait aller
vers un processus d'autodétermination et
d'indépendance mais à paris les luttes
sont comme ça il ya des attentats tous
les jours vous parlez du 17 octobre
mais pardon de dire que les chiffres que
vous citez 200 morts buts 7 octobre
c'est le livre que je connais
parfaitement de elodie la bataille de
paris où il dit ailleurs 246 et on a
fait depuis et avec lui et en
contradiction
un décalage qui fait qu'en réalité il
des comptes
allez on va simplifier les morts parce
que malheureusement on a tous les jours
de l'ensemble du mois d'octobre pas que
du 17 octobre
mais souvenons nous aussi en sens
inverse
sauf dans le mail je suis disposée je ne
sais pas moi qui décide mais moi je suis
plutôt court quand nous les archives
l'historienne je suis est entièrement
d'accord là dessus qu'on ouvre qu'on
ouvre et que et qu'on fasse une étude
objective en regardant qui a fait quoi
et dans quelles conditions mais là
dessus tout le monde est d'accord pour
que la vérité historique soit dit
ouvrant les archives
regardons ce qui a été donné pour
instruction à ce que vous dites monsieur
laurent oui le préfet de police 10 pour
un coup porté
dix seront rendus par dont il n'a pas
dit ça comme instruction je le dis quand
même à l'assemblée il n'a pas dit ça
comme instructions à la police pour le
17 octobre
il a dit ça le 2 octobre 2009 161 aux
obsèques du brigadier chef 2 - qui avait
été assassiné par le fln alors que le
ministre de l'intérieur
disons le préfet de police dise aux
obsèques d'un policier tué par le fln eh
bien oui je veux protéger la police
pardon de vous rappeler parce que faut
pas faire l'histoire à sens unique les
syndicalistes policiers de l'époque qui
sont souvent des syndicalistes policiers
plutôt classé à gauche il y avait déjà à
l'époque monatte le fameux jarmo nat qui
était déjà un syndicaliste policier et
qui lui aussi disait il faut protéger la
police entre le 29 août et le 2 octobre
1961 33 attentats
le fln contre la police 33 13 morts
treize policiers tués et plusieurs
dizaines de blessés
voilà le climat alors non mais vous
dites et alors
et vous pensez sincèrement que c'est
dans un climat serein et que d'un coup
il y aurait un déchaînement policiers
n'y a rien enfin c'est évident vous êtes
en pleine guerre d'algérie il ya des
milliers de morts en algérie il ya des
assassinats tous les jours à paris il ya
des attaques contre la police tous les
jours à paris tous les jours et des
policier meurt et plein de policiers
sont blessés et des familles et c'est la
lutte entre l'ol qui n'épargne pas le
régime gaulliste
le fln le mn à est tout tout seul à tous
ces extrémistes quelque part tous ceux
qui commettent des attentats
tu es quand ils tuent ils tuent des
policiers d'abord parce que c'est la
police qui est visé et les commandos du
fln
reçu des instructions très claires pour
viser d'abord la police et vous savez
parfaitement faux pas réécrire
l'histoire
vous savez parfaitement qu'on a un vrai
sujet j'espère que les archives le
montreront quand on ira dedans entre le
gpr à qui dit un moment on demande une
trêve jusqu'à la fin des négociations
avec le gouvernement français pour
aboutir à l'indépendance et la
fédération fln de paris devant avec des
rased qui dit non nous nous continuons
le gp le gpr à le gpr à demande aux
français musulmans de respecter le
couvre-feu qui a été effectivement
installé à paris pour empêcher les
attentats et le fln refuse le couvre-feu
et demande à ce que les attentats se
poursuivent
voilà la réalité alors après ça c'est la
vérité
après vous pouvez dire est ce qu'il y a
eu le 17 octobre thé débordements est ce
qu'il y a eu le 17 octobre des actes non
mais attendez des actes policiers qui
n'aurait pas dû être
mais d'ailleurs il ya plusieurs rapports
de police de l'époque qui disent il ya
même un rapport pour ne rien cacher de
gérard monatte lui-même puisque les
syndicats de police était à l'époque
extrêmement fort et jarmo nat fait un
rapport où il signale point par point
un certain nombre de débordements ou de
dérapages ou d'actes policiers qu'il
qualifie lui-même syndicaliste policier
d'inacceptable et des sanctions vont
être prises par la suite donc on n'a pas
découvert il faut pas venir nous dire
qu'est ce que c'est il ya d'un coup un
crime d'état comme je lé vu écrit dans
certains journaux et pardon de dire
pardon de dire que j'ai lu hier ou
avant-hier dans le monde
un interview où on dit et bien jacques
chirac a reconnu la responsabilité de
l'état de vichy de l'état français il
faut reconnaître la responsabilité de
l'état français en 1961 non mais c'est
écrit noir sur blanc dans l'interview
dans le monde
c'est écrit comme ça pardon de vous dire
que je trouve hallucinatoire franchement
je le dis à tout le monde
gauche droite
on peut pas mettre ça sur le même plan
vous pouvez pas dire le régime de vichy
que moi se considère comme et raging
totalement illégitime qui a collaboré
qui a fait en sorte de mettre à la
disposition de l'allemagne et des
régimes nazis la police française et
l'ensemble de la structure française
et dire qu'il faut dans le même temps et
dans la même comparaison reconnaître la
responsabilité de l'état français en
1961 en 1961
peut-être n'êtes-vous pas d'accord avec
ce qui était majoritaire à l'époque mais
le général de gaulle était président la
république
les élections législatives avait conduit
une majorité lui nerfs d'alliora élargi
puisque non la majorité pur qu'en 1962
mais ce sont les institutions légales
légitimes des gouvernants qui ne sont
pas des gouvernants de rencontrer des
gouvernants qui ne sont pas imposées par
l'ennemi et la police monsieur laurent
seront pas ce que vous dites quand vous
dites je trouve inacceptable de parler
la police de la république
mais oui et oui parce que pardon de vous
rappeler les regarder même les résultats
parce que ça aussi c'est dans les
archives que ça y'a pas besoin ce pas
leurs sources secrètes les résultats des
élections syndicales dans la police au
début des années 60
la gauche fait 80% nommé la gauche fait
80%
qu'est-ce qui c'est c'est quoi ces
policiers nous il sortait ses policiers
voté à 80 % pour les syndicats de gosse
et puis d'un coup relais mais dans une
manif ça devient des espèces de 2,2 de
monstres bien sûr que non bien sûr que
non
et les arbres bébé mais je souhaite
qu'on trouve parce que tout ce que l'on
en sait des instructions données entre
le 2 et le 17 octobre à maurice papon
vous n'avez aucun ordre aucun ordre qui
soit et qui dépasse les limites de la
république aucun et vous pouvez regarder
on à l'instruction du 17 au matin du 17
au matin
oui demande à ce que les gens soient
respectées ou il dit je demande à la
police de maintenir l'ordre le calme la
sécurité mais je lui demande de
respecter les individus qui ont du mali
c'est ce qu'a donc qui ensuite vous
disiez n'avait qu'ensuite vous disiez il
ya eu sur les ponts il ya eu un certain
nombre de dérapages
et des morts bien sûr des morts fin mai
des morts mais enfin madame dans
l'histoire politique en france
combien de manifestations où il ya eu
des morts mais non madame je vous
interromps pas un bon oui mais ne le
dites pas n'importe quoi ya pas deux il
n'y a pas deux dans des moments
insurrectionnelle dans des guerres comme
la guerre d'algérie bien sûr qu'on
aurait précieux qui est pas un mort dans
les grèves insurrectionnelles de 1947 ya
des morts jules moch la craie les crs
c'est un mini socialiste qui créent les
crs pour les greffes d'insurrection de
47 demandé à ce qu'on reconnaisse les
crimes de monsieur jules moch enfin un
moment un moment il faut respecter
l'histoire et ne pas la dénaturer moi je
vous dis simplement je vous dis
simplement qu'on ouvre les archives
parfait que chacun assume
après une étude historique objective
parce que les choses soient faites dans
la clarté et l'historienne je suis en
sera ravi par fait qu'on ait accès à
tous qu'il n'y ait plus de 2 de
documents classés surclassé pour cogner
pas que sais je suis entièrement
d'accord mais lorsqu'on aura fait le
point lorsqu'on aura fait la vérité
alors on verra que la république en 1961
ya ptet ya sans doute eu il ya
évidemment du ska des morts il ya eu des
dérives
il ya eu des dérapages il ya eu des
bavures comme on dit mais au-delà de ça
est ce que pour autant il faut mettre en
cause la responsabilité de la république
est ce que pour autant mais non sinon
vous mettrez la responsabilité la
république en cause chaque fois qu'il ya
un dérapage chaque fois mettons en cause
les responsabilités de ceux qui ont
dérapé
voyons dans quelles conditions ça s'est
passé mais si les instructions du préfet
de police ne sont pas d'une nature qui
dépasse la légalité républicaine qu'est
ce que vous allez mettre en cause en
vrai allons les instructions du ministre
les instructions du préfet de police ne
sont pas des instructions qui outrepasse
et qui violent les lois de la république
voilà la vérité pardon
monsieur assouline
s'il y avait été jouée mais sincèrement
je dois dire c'est facile sous les
dorures du sénat d'oublier qu'en 1961
les commissariats explose
les policiers sont abattues ya la guerre
civile il ya en algérie des milliers des
dizaines de milliers de morts
parce que j'aimerais vous entendre aussi
sur tous les massacres sur toutes les
responsabilités des harkis et des autres
tout le monde et il faudrait la vérité
sur tout et je souhaite la vérité sur
tout et qu'on ouvre les archives sur
tout mais pour autant ne dit pas qu'il
faut reconnaître la responsabilité de la
république parce que quelque part vous
mettez en cause les institutions de la
république
et quelque part vous mettez en cause oui
je le dis comme christian jacob la
police républicaine et à l'époque
c'était franchement une police
républicaine très marquée plutôt de
votre côté que de l'autre mais c'est
comme ça mais c'est comme ça mais c'est
comme ça mais c'est comme ça et c'est
meinau mais moi je ne cherche pas je
vous dis seulement que mettre en cause
la police en 1961
ça n'a pas de sens et ben oui très bas
c'est c'est très bien mais c'est ce
qu'on dit bas donc ne mettez pas en
cause
si vous si la police y ait un public n
ne la mettez pas en cause oui bien sûr
on va faire des demandes d'excusés à la
police maintenant la france franche bord
est un pays où peut pas dire que
l'histoire est toujours été d'une
sérénité totale peut pas dire de tous
les côtés et dans tous les camps il ya
eu beaucoup beaucoup de souffrance
beaucoup de sang beaucoup de malheurs
beaucoup de misère mais cette république
et cette histoire c'est la nôtre si vous
chercher chaque fois et à chaque épisode
à trouver des responsables et à mettre
en cause la responsabilité de la
république
alors je vous le dis sincèrement la
république elle est bien mal parti
merci dans la suite du débat la parole
est à monsieur david assouline
oui malheureusement je vais avoir un
temps bresse qui ne peut pas vous
restituer ce que je sais ce que j'ai
appris sur cette époque et notamment sur
ces faits puisque comme historien j'ai
travaillé plusieurs années sur cette
manifestation
et cette répression quand c'était une
chape de plomb
on ne pouvait pas accéder aux archives
il y avait des témoignages vivants de ce
qu'ils avaient subi de ceux qui
courageusement avait tout de suite
témoigné hier des bauges et à ce que qui
ont été cités tout à l'heure à la
tribune il ya eu des débats ici
gaston defferre ici a demandé une
commission d'enquêté ça avait été
rejetée ensuite il y a eu au moins
trente ans qu'on en parle par une
extrême jeunes qui a envahi toute la
classe politique et tous les acteurs qui
avaient du mal à présent à appréhender
cet événement parce que al'inverse de ce
que vous dites monsieur karoutchi c'est
ça la singularité c'est qu'il y avait
une guerre qui tirait à sa fin
mais ce soir-là à paris on s'était
pressée à l'inauguration du rayon
bonneterie de la samaritaine
les gars j'étais en les gars étaient
engorgés
parce qu'il y avait une grève de la sncf
le soir même il y avait des milliers de
badauds qui allait au cinéma qu'elle est
au spectacle qui manger au restaurant
tranquillement on s'inquiétait du sort
de johnny hallyday parce que il venait
d'avoir un accident de voiture et donc
cette guerre d'algérie oui il y avait et
qui faisait tant de malheurs à paris il
y avait une vie qui continue est une
république une police républicaine des
institutions des débats démocratiques et
dans cette situation quand vingt mille
personnes venant des bidonvilles et les
quartiers populaires de la région
parisienne viennent souiller à la sortie
des bidonvilles pour qu'il n'ait pas eu
n'est pas
veut dans leur pantalon pour qu'ils
soient sûrs qu'il n'y a aucune
provocation pour protester contre un
couvre-feu imposé par maurice papon
ancien secrétaire général de la
préfecture de gironde sous vichy et qui
est un couvre-feu particulier monsieur k
aussi parce que il ne touche pas la
population parce qu'à la guerre il
touche uniquement les français nord
africains parce qu'ils sont français et
donc pour un policier appliqué ce
couvre-feu
ça ne peut se faire qu au faciès à la
couleur de la peau a l'impression que
l'on a acquis les maghrébins d'origine
mais français et donc pour protester
contre cela il y à une manifestation on
a jeté dans la seine
on a fracassé des crânes avec des
crosses et pas seulement des bidules et
c'est pas fini derrière il y a eu ses
15000 arrêté entre 13 et 15 bis et le
bilan officiel vous vous rendez compte
la police elle même ne sait pas à ce
moment là combien elle en a arrêté entre
13 et 15 mille cent vingt mille
manifestants c'est le bilan officiel
et ça continue dans les endroits où ils
ont été arrêtés dans le figaro dans
plusieurs journaux qui de toutes
obédiences il ya des journalistes qui
témoigna les traces de ce qu'il voit
être une horreur et c'est pour cela
aussi que ça a été enfoui dans la
mémoire collective parce que tout le
monde a un peu vu et c'est resté en
dessous c'est pas seulement les méchants
là haut qui éteignent le feu c'est que
dans une france républicaine ça pu se
produire et la première leçon
monsieur karoutchi que l'on doit en
tirer c'est que des fois il ya des
basculements de régime et c'est clair ja
vichy il ya les résistants et d'autres
fois dans l'histoire de notre vie
démocratique il y a en notre sein même
des dérapages possibles et ne
reconnaîtra un moment donné c'est un
appel à la vigilance de tous les
instants pour que dans notre démocratie
nous restions vigilants par rapport à ça
alors vous allez me dire
et le mort d'ici et de là mais voyons on
est au sénat
on ne s'en voit pas les morts à la
figure la civils tués en algérie disparu
ils font une reconnaissance ou sinon là
la blessure ne se referme pas les harkis
il faut cette reconnaissance parce que
sinon la blessure continue
pourquoi 51 ans après nous sommes encore
dans cette situation à devoir en
discuter de façon passionnée à cause du
fait qu'il y a des chapes de plomb
si c'était dit la vérité
aps des blessures permet de tourner les
pages permet la paix permet de se
tourner vers l'avenir et c'est cette
reconnaissance qu'a fait le président de
la république et il n'a pas montré une
faiblesse de la république
il a montré sa force la force de ses
valeurs
quand on dit la vérité et toute la
vérité ici ou là doit être dit à ce
moment-là on peut envisager l'avenir on
peut soigner réellement les blessures et
ont peint monsieur karoutchi et on peut
monsieur karoutchi faire quelque chose
d'indispensable
ne laissez aucune prise à ceux qui
instrumentalisent ces moments de
blessure et cn pour les alimenter et
pour enfermer les uns et réseaux dans
des fosses d'identité parce que dans
cette histoire
l'histoire a été racontée à des petits
enfants à des enfants et ils ont lu dans
les livres que ça n'était pas raconté
que dans leur histoire c'est l'histoire
de france cette chose été oubliés et
bien entendu ça reste ça reste comme
quelque chose comme un non 10 comme
quelque chose qui empêche aujourd'hui la
république a besoin de se rassembler de
se rassembler clairement de se
rassembler avec force
aucun événement si vous reconnaissez
c'est mort si vous les reconnaissez vous
l'avez fait ici ça pas toujours été le
cas
et bien je peux vous dire que
que c'est déjà un grand pas je veux
finir sur sur cet art et histoire tout
ce que vous allez décrire l'ambiance des
tués policiers etc
mais bien sûr c'est ça qui peut
expliquer qu'après il ya une telle
sauvagerie
mais il y à des responsables qui sont là
y compris si ça dérape
sinon on se tient plus si on se met à
faire n'importe quoi parce qu'on est
pris dans la folie d'une action ça a
duré des heures
il ya là un préfet de police chez lui
une salle de commandement ou s'esquive
pas dans le moindre recoin de la
capitale alors au moins si on n'a pas
donné l'ordre de le faire on peut
arrêter que ça se fasse
alors je veux vous dire arrêter j'ai
travaillé là dessus il ya des archives
officielles qui ont été sorties où il
est établi qu'il ya eu plusieurs
dizaines de morts
or le bilan officiel ces neuf blessés
légers
du côté des forces de l'ordre vous
connaissez une manifestation où des deux
côtés ça dégénère on se fout dessus de
partout et donc il n'y a pas de
responsables comme a dit monsieur guaino
où il y a quinze mille arrestations des
dizaines de morts d'un côté et neuf
blessés légers du côté des forces de
l'ordre même aujourd'hui ce serait
impossible bien entendu sans qu'il y ait
mort s'il y a quinze mille arrestations
je pense que il y aurait plus de
turbulences donc sur les faits comme sur
le sens de ce qui nous est demandé
aujourd'hui
arrêtons de s'envoyer les morts des uns
ou des autres
tous les morts méritent reconnaissance
tous et c'est comme ça qu'on passe à
autre chose que la paix se fait que la
fraternité se fait que l'unité de la
république ce fait et en votant cet
article unique très bref qui nous est
proposé sans partage est forcément tous
les attendus qui ont été exposés ici
messieurs si sa tactique unies la
reconnaissance officielle
elle a été faite par le président de la
république la semaine dernière des
archives doivent continuer à être
ouverte pour que l'on puisse établir
plus précisément les faits mais ce que
l'on sait déjà mérité
ce geste mérite pas du tout eu de
polémique là-dessus et je vous le dis on
mériterait tous à se rassembler quand il
s'agit de faire ça pour les uns et pour
les autres et pour l'avenir
merci dans la suite de la discussion
la parole est à monsieur guy fischer
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues après les
propos de pierre laurent je ne
reviendrai pas sur son argumentation qui
témoigne s'il en était besoin de la
nécessité de reconnaître même 51 ans
après la responsabilité de l'état
français dans l'une des plus terribles
tragédies engendrés par le fait colonial
jeudi reviendrai pas sinon pour
motoriser un témoignage personnel trop
jeune pour partir en algérie
j'avais 18 ans 62 je n'en est pas moins
à l'époque militer pour la fin de cette
guerre de toutes les guerres coloniales
et pour la paix en algérie
si comme je le pense nous adoptons
après-demain la proposition de loi
faisons du 19 mars la journée nationale
du souvenir et du recueillement à la
mémoire des victimes civiles et
militaires de la guerre d'algérie et des
combats en tunisie et au maroc
j'aurai vécu en la même semaine un
double point d'orgue à un combat que
j'ai toujours mené en tant que militant
puis en tant que parlementaire cela me
ramène à la source de mon engagement
ma prise de conscience d'adolescents à
partir de la guerre d'algérie qui a
marqué mon histoire personnelle est fait
pour moi du combat anticolonialiste un
repère à jamais incontournable
ineffaçable
à partir de là j'ai toujours été
déterminé à combattre non seulement le
déni du passé colonial de notre pays
mais y compris ses prolongements que
sont par exemple la poursuite du pillage
des richesses naturelles des anciennes
colonies comme la recrudescence des
agissements des tenants de l'algérie
française et des nostalgiques de l'oas
j'ai vécu très concrètement le
négationnisme d'état au cours de mes
mandats de sénateur
en quelques circonstances symbolique qui
m'ont particulièrement marqué je pense
au temps et à l'énergie qu'il aura fallu
aux nombreuses compositions de loi
déposée par mon groupe pour obtenir
enfin un soir du 5 octobre 1999
l'adoption d'une proposition de loi
remplaçant le vocable d'opérations par
le terme guerre d'algérie je pense aussi
à la tristement célèbre loi du 23
février 2005 que le groupe communiste du
sénat a été bien seul à dénoncer à son
article 4 heureusement retoquée par le
conseil constitutionnel qui gravait dans
le marbre de la loi les bienfaits de la
colonisation
comment ne pas citer henri alleg qui
écrivait récemment l'anticolonialisme
aujourd'hui c'est le refus de tout
réécriture officielle du passé colonial
c'est le combat contre la soumission des
peuples ce combat c'est aussi celui du
peuple palestinien martyr des français
des antilles toujours sous la domination
économique sans partage des descendants
des colons esclavagistes et de tant
d'autres hommes et femmes j'y suis allé
monsieur karoutchi
j'ai vu et je pourrais vous citer le nom
des familles qui de génération en
génération depuis plus d'un siècle et
bien se transmettre le pouvoir
économique et politique auquel le nez
que néocolonialisme dénis aujourd'hui
encore le droit élémentaire à disposer
d'eux mêmes si je refuse que l'on oublie
les milliers d'algériens qui furent
arrêtés battus torturés assassinés par
la police française sous les ordres de
maurice papon préfet de police lui-même
couvert par gouvernement d'un même je
refuse que l'on abandonne tous ceux qui
se débattent encore sous d'implacables
joue hérité d'un autre temps un
demi-siècle après ce que je ne suis pas
ça la dénommée un crime d'état je me
félicite de constater
kohno combat de plusieurs décennies ont
porté leurs fruits le voile du silence
et de l'oubli c'est enfin déchiré il
reste à présent à obtenir de notre
nouveau gouvernement
la reconnaissance plus globale de la
responsabilité de la france dans les
guerres coloniales qu'elle amenait
particulièrement en algérie avec son
cortège d'horreurs 40 travail historique
et un travail de mémoire s'impose pour
cette période y compris et surtout sur
ses zones d'ombré c'est en effet à ce
prix que pourrait disparaître les
séquelles les plus graves de la guerre
d'algérie le racisme et les
discriminations dont sont victimes
encore aujourd'hui les ressortissants
d'origine algérienne du maghreb ou
d'anciennes colonies
j'ai été élu pendant 26 ans conseiller
général des minguettes où la communauté
algérienne française d'origine
algérienne est largement mis non
majoritaire c'est pourquoi notre
proposition de résolution et votent non
seulement la reconnaissance officielle
du crime commis par l'état français le
17 octobre 61 mais également la création
d'un lieu de souvenir à la mémoire de
ces victimes du colonialisme sur ces
questions j'étais confiant j'avais en
effet avec ma collègue nicole borvo
cohen seat adressé un courrier au
président françois hollande
c'était en juillet de cette année à
propos de la reconnaissance du passé
colonial de la france et de ses
tragiques conséquences
sa réponse évoquant l'opportunité d'un
grand traité d'amitié motorisés à qu'on
sait que nous étions en voie de mettre
enfin un terme aux conséquences d'un
très lourd passé qui empoisonne les
relations entre les deux rives de la
méditerranée
quel ne fut toutefois pas ma surprise de
constater qu'ils étaient toujours
d'actualité
une initiative pour le moins en
contradiction avec la volonté
présidentielle affichée
écoutez bien le seul ministre je veux
parler du transfert des cendres du
général bi
ja mémorial de fréjus il semblerait que
le ministre de la défense monsieur jean
yves le drian n'est pas renoncer à
commettre cet acte inconsidéré et je
suis mesuré honorer la mémoire de l'un
des tortionnaires et les des pages les
plus noires des guerres d'indochine et
d'algérie
à mon sens cela mérite réflexion
je voudrais ici témoigner de
l'incompréhension de mes amis membres
d'autorités luttant depuis des années
pour la reconnaissance de la tragédie du
17 octobre 61
notre joie a été gâchée distille nous ne
comprenons pas que l'on avance d'un pas
et que l'on recule de 2 dans le même
temps comme je les comprends car la
mémoire assume et ne peut se concevoir
que comme un tout on ne peut pas
prétendre considéré sur des bases saines
les relations d'amitié entre deux
peuples sans considérer les événements
dans leur globalité reconnaître la
responsabilité de l'état français le 17
octobre 61 d'un côté oublié les
massacres de sétif en 45 les morts du
métro charonne la disparition du
mathématicien communiste maurice audin
le tragique abandon des harkis la misère
des rapatriés l' os et ses exactions
non cela ne se peut j'ose donc espérer
que la raison l'emportera et je suis
signataire avec plusieurs personnalités
d'horizons très divers d'un manifeste
contre le rapatriement des cendres de du
général bigeard
je conclurai en vous appelant mes chers
collègues à oeuvrer ensemble pour une
réponse cohérente et globale aux
attentes des populations qui des deux
côtés de la méditerranée aspire depuis
si longtemps à la construction d'une
solide et saine amitié qui nous a
quittés d'un passé dont les conséquences
n'ont que trop pervertit les chances
d'un futur apaisé merci
merci monsieur dit fisher la parole est
à monsieur yves pozzo di borgo
pendant monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues le 17
octobre 1961 la france était en guerre
cette guerre est encore pudiquement
appelée crise algérienne sans doute vous
voulez temps masqué le fraticide
derrière la sémantique pour ne pas voir
à quel point nous nous déchirons avec un
pays qui a partagé notre destin national
pendant près de cent cinquante ans et
qui est toujours entre voisins
cette guerre est une plaie béante dans
notre histoire nombreuses sont les
familles en france comme en algérie qui
ont été frappés par le tragique de
l'histoire
les événements du 17 octobre 61 sont
sans conteste l'un des épisodes les plus
dramatiques les circonstances de
l'époque ont infligé aux français aux
algériens cet épisode n'est pas le seul
des massa qui en a eu beaucoup
aucun n'est justifiable quelles que
soient les circonstances
alors certes ya la guerre mais derrière
cette raison la réalité est bien plus
sordide sétif en 1945 la toussaint
sanguins dans 54 constantine en 55
l'opération d'âge et ensuite et comme et
d'autres attentats de l'oas en france à
l'algérie la torture en algérie le
massacre des harkis et bien d'autres la
guerre d'algérie confronte encore les
mémoires cinquante ans après les accords
d'evian toute la lumière n'a pas été
faite pour permettre aux deuils à
l'oubli au pardon de combler cette large
bissieux pour nos deux peuples
sans doute faut-il laisser le temps
faire son travail or ce travail qui le
nôtre titre plutôt celui mes chers
collègues celui d historia le parlement
bien qu'il représente le peuple français
n'est pas le tribunal de l'histoire
je ne crois pas qu'il nous revient de
décider de ce qui devrait être tenu
notre passé ce travail est avant tout
celui des historiens celui des
scientifiques indépendants dont la tâche
est de nous mettre face à la réalité
factuelle de l'histoire et pas devant un
quelconque une quelconque pussions
mémorielle cette justice n'est pas la
nôtre
elle n'est pas de notre ressort du moins
pas d'une manière aussi ni latéral mes
chers collègues les lois mémorielles ont
souvent conduit le parlement sortir de
son rôle dans sa qualité de jce l'acteur
la présente proposition de résolution
sur les 6 notre rôle tribu
ni siens mais en aucun cas la
constitution nous donne compétence en
matière historique
si la loi ne dispose que pour l'avenir
il s'en va de soi que les résolutions
soient des prises de position pour
l'avenir et pas les races des ateliers
de l'historien nous pouvons saluer
l'initiative du groupe communiste qui
nous permet ainsi de poser les premiers
jalons de ce qui aurait dû être un grand
débat national sur les commémorations
nous pourrions également nous satisfaire
de ce que cette initiative ait su si
rapidement trouvé l'oreille du président
de la république
pour autant je ne peux m'empêcher et mon
groupe avec de regretter que la feue
requêtes formulées par cette résolution
mes chers collègues se soit achevée par
un simple communiqué de presse ou
l'elysée nous annonce laconiquement que
la france reconnaît avec lucidité sa
responsabilité devant les événements du
7 17 octobre 1961
j'ai pourtant la ferme conviction qu'on
n'est jamais aussi lucide que lorsque
l'on est deux cette initiative dû faire
l'objet d'un vaste débat national soit
mais ce débat aurait dû aussi se faire
en association avec nos amis algériens
en effet et la douloureuse question des
mémoires de gaye l'algérie ne serait
être unilatérale plus de 150 européens
pour un exemple pour été tué par le fln
lors d'un première phase du massage de
constantine en 55 en 1955 le massacre de
melouza été rasés
c'est 315 habitants en femmes et enfants
ont été massacrées par le fln et
pourquoi pas ce qu'ils jettent et des
indépendantistes du mn à favorable à
messali hadj
voilà l'absurdité de l'histoire pourquoi
ne commémorons pas non plus ces drames
qui se souvient de ses victimes dont
elle pas elle aussi droit aux souvenirs
on ne serait demandé la reconnaissance
17 octobre sans demander à jerry
d'effectuer ce même travail sur
elle-même
il faut être deux pour faire une guerre
et nombreux sont les familles françaises
avoir été frappé et les familles à gérer
à avoir frappé par ce qui s'est produit
ya plus d'un demi-siècle au sud à
méditerranée cette question si elle est
légitime n'aurait pas dû à traiter de
cette manière il ne s'agit pas de nous
satisfaire
dans notre coin d'avoir reconnu nos
torts et de nous complaire dans une
certaine autosatisfaction
il ne s'agit pas non plus de n'augure et
une quelconque stèle pour y déposer des
fleurs la faveur du calendrier
commémoratif nous pour le faire
engrosser de paris mais pas au parlement
le gouvernement a été vertement
critiquée pour son goût prononcé pour
les commissions ans je trouve mes chers
collègues que s'il ya bien un sujet sur
lequel gouvernement rhdp eu bien raison
de mettre en oeuvre cette méthode c'est
bien sur cette question des
reconnaissances et des commémorations
ainsi mes chers collègues
les sénateurs du groupe union centriste
dans sa grande majorité ne sont pas
favorables en l'état à cette proposition
de résolution
nous demandons en revanche parce qu'une
large concertation soit organisé en
association avec l'algérie par le biais
de groupes d'amitiés d'autres c'est
seulement en avance ensemble dans la
réciprocité et dans le parallélisme que
nous parviendrons peut-être à trouver
chacun de notre côté de la mer les
justes mots vers la route du pardon
mutuel
c'est la seule voie raisonnable enfin de
rendre justice à l'ensemble des victimes
de toutes les exactions commises pendant
cette guerre c'est la seule voie
possible pour parvenir à rendre justice
même tout symbolique aux familles
françaises algérienne qui continue de
part et d'autre de la mer et du siècle à
souffrir des zones d'ombré des mensonges
d'états des deux côtés et du sang
inutilement verser dimanche dernier jean
louis borloo a lancé un appel aux
progressistes aux patriotes les rangs
dans un monde qui change
les représentations de l'histoire change
également
nous devons tendre la main à nos amis
algériens dans la voie du rassemblement
et de la pacification
rappelons nous et je terminerai par
cette phrase ces mots écrits par al
baker
albert camus dans une lettre un miltant
j rien de 1955
c'est mieux de soucis tous cherchent à
faire l'essentiel est de mettre devenir
si restreinte faute elle la place du
dialogue encore possible et pour cela il
faut que chacun nous prêchent
l'apaisement aux siens si vos autres
démocrates arabes fois ici à votre
talent d'apaisement notre action à nous
français libéraux sera d' avance vouée à
l'échelle je vous remercie
excusez-moi de maison merci monsieur
aujourd'hui borgo dans la suite du débat
la parole est à monsieur robert hue
c'est le président monsieur le ministre
mes chers collègues
il aura fallu cinquante et un ans pour
que la france par la voix du président
de la république reconnaisse la
sanglante répression du 17 octobre 1961
dont ont été victimes de nombreux
algériens qui manifestaient
pacifiquement pour l'indépendance de
leur pays colonisés cette reconnaissance
était un engagement du président de la
république
le voici tenue je m'en félicite vivement
je ne reviens pas ici sur la description
des événements chacun on connaît la
teneur
ça a été largement évoquée et bien
évoqué et c'est aux historiens que
revient ce travail de mise en lumière et
de clarification des faits combien de
morts de blessés de tabasser de noyer
des dizaines voire des centaines cette
tragédie est encore entouré d'un silence
qui ne pourra être rompu que par
l'ouverture des archives et notamment
celle de la police et de la justice
si les crimes ont été reconnus il n'en
demeure pas moins que les criminels ne
sont eux toujours pas identifiée je ne
souhaite pas ici exposé les faits qui
sont connues de tous
ce qui m'intéresse avant tout c'est ce
que ces faits démontrent et ce qu'ils
engendrent cette proposition de
résolution nous renvoie ainsi à notre
propre histoire
pendant des décennies la france a
préféré mettre ces événements sous le
tapis nous le savons tous l'histoire de
france foisonnent l'événement tragique
comme elle foisonne aussi d'épisodes de
fierté et d'émancipation mais il serait
illusoire de penser que notre pays peut
aller de l'avant en maquillant son
histoire en dissimulant ce qui le gêne
mes chers collègues il faut regarder les
choses en face
c'est l'honneur de la france que de
reconnaître ses erreurs j'entends bien
sur la droite et l'extrême droite
s'indigner et vociférer contre je ne
sais quel repentance mais mes chers
collègues qu'y at il de si honteux de si
déshonorant à regarder la réalité en
face
car c'est cela qui importe reconnaître
la vérité sans repentance sans
flagellation au nom de la mémoire
nous le devons aux victimes et à leurs
familles
certes tout ceci a eu lieu dans le
contexte de la guerre une guerre que les
autorités au pouvoir refusé d'appeler
par son nom la guerre par définition
entraînent des drames comme pour tout
bière il ne nous revient pas aujourd'hui
ici de remplacer le travail des
historiens mais il s'agit simplement de
reconnaître des faits des crimes qui
n'aurait jamais dû avoir lieu
nous connaissons tous
l'ambiguïté de la droite dès qu'il
s'agit du système colonial sont naturels
idéologique de vouloir justifier les
drames et les crimes qu'il a engendré en
tentant parfois sans y parvenir de
légiférer sur les aspects positifs de la
colonisation
nous connaissons aussi la véritable
nostalgie de l'extrême droite à l'égard
de cette période dramatique qui n'honore
pas notre pays au lieu de vouloir
justifier ce qu'il faut bien appeler un
comportement néocolonial il conviendrait
surtout de rappeler aux jeunes la
réalité qu'elle soit du fait de la
france ou non et surtout dans nos blir
ce grand principe qu'est le droit des
peuples à disposer d'eux mêmes je vois
bien qu'à droite les tentations sont
fortes de maintenir un mythe de la
colonisation positive et pour diviser
nos concitoyens sur notre histoire
commune
les propos affligeants affligeant je le
dis d'eads messieurs jacob et fillon
fustigeant un soi-disant discours de
culpabilité de françois hollande n'ont
rien à envier aux propos du front
national dont la présidente affirme que
la france se trouve sali par la
reconnaissance de ces faits historiques
nous voyons encore avec ce débat
aujourd'hui la france a du mal avec son
passé colonial il est pourtant
nécessaire d'assumer ce passé et de le
regarder sereinement en toute lucidité
afin d'aller vers l'avant
je considère par exemple à bien des
égards que nous ne pourrons jamais
refermé la page de la françafrique
tant que nous laisserons perdurer des
zones de flou dans notre histoire
commune avec ce continent
car si nous voulons vraiment enfin
tourné la page comme l'a déclaré le
président de la république à dakar le 12
octobre dernier et c'est son honneur
il nous faut d'abord ne rien oublier
il est ainsi important de pouvoir
disposer d'un lieu du souvenir comme le
propose le texte qui nous est soumis
si la république reconnaît avec lucidité
ces erreurs c'est d'abord pour regarder
notre avenir commun avec l'algérie
habitée du respect mutuel de solidarité
utile et de volonté affirmée d'une
coopération sincère
le déplacement du président de la
république en algérie en décembre
prochain doit marquer une nouvelle ère
dans la rue dans les relations franco
algériennes
je souhaite également que la coopération
soit renforcée nous savons aussi que la
solidarité franco algérienne est
nécessaire pour la sécurité de nos
peuples respectifs et pour la stabilité
d'une grande partie du monde et
particulièrement aujourd'hui au sahel et
au mali l'algérie est un grand pays
souverain avec lequel plus que jamais la
france et l'europe doivent compter il
est temps que notre pays tissent des
liens de confiance avec l'algérie notre
passé est douloureux il faut maintenant
tout faire pour que notre avenir commun
soit celui d'une grande et durable
pitié tels sont mes chers collègues
assurent le ministre monsieur le
président telles sont les raisons qui
conduira une majorité des membres du
groupe rds a voté cette proposition de
résolution du groupe crc
merci monsieur robert hue la parole est
à madame esther benbassa
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre
la déclaration de françois hollande le
17 octobre 2012 reconnaissant la
répression sanglante de manifestants
algériens 51 ans plus tôt a été
accueilli à gauche avec soulagement même
si nous pouvons regretter aujourd'hui
l'absence du ministre de l'intérieur
dans cet hémicycle étroitement organisé
par la fédération de france du fln
encadrés par le sict consignes de
discipline pourrait voûte pour éviter
tout débordement
la manifestation pacifique du 17 octobre
réunissez aux côtés des hommes de très
nombreuses femmes ce qu'on oublie de
dire
elle visait à faire prendre conscience à
la poule à la population de la férocité
de la répression policière s'abattant
sur les travailleurs algériens
enlèvements et assassinats se succéder
sans relâche à quoi depuis le 6 octobre
un décret discriminatoire du préfet de
police avait ajouté l'interdiction aux
seuls algériens de sortir après 20
heures dans la région parisienne
ce préfet n'était autre que maurice
papon
celui là même qui on le saurait plus
tard avait déporté 1600 juive en juillet
1942 et juin 1944 de bordeaux à drancy
tous partiront ensuite devenu préfet de
police de la seine c'est lui qui avait
organisé cette véritable guerre contre
les immigrés algériens avec la pluie
l'appui du premier ministre d'alors
michel debré un des premiers documents
relatant la sanglante répression du 17
octobre 1961 et le reportage préparait
pour le journal libération de l'époque
première version par paulette péju
publié intégralement sous sa signature
et sous celle de son mari marcel péju
dès novembre 1961 aux éditions maspero
accompagné de clichés intitulée
ratonnades à paris ce document fut
aussitôt saisi par la police comme
d'autres ouvrages qui paraîtront
marcel péju donc un de ses auteurs de
ceux de cet ouvrage lui même journaliste
raconte je le cite le soir du 17 octobre
1961 en compagnie de claude lanzmann
nous sortions de chaque de chez jacques
vergès à cette époque l'un des avocats
du fln en arrivant près de la place de
l'étoile
tandis que des crs eux refoulés
brutalement un groupe d'algériens
nous nous sommes trouvés face à un
policier qui tout seul au milieu du
trottoir
blondissez un revolver au dessus de sa
tête et l'udc tentent d injures et
clients qu'il fallait fusillé ben bella
impossible de gagner les grands
boulevards où se déroulait l'une des
plus importantes manifestations
férocement réprimées le lendemain matin
au journal libération travail est ma
femme c'est toujours péju qui raconte je
vis connaissance du photographe
elie kagan tout ému encore et qui lui
montrait les atroces photos qu'il avait
prises
le climat était patent et pourtant comme
les clips les époux péju des le clim
commença sa dissimulation
l'historien gilles manceron donne trois
raisons à cette conspiration du silence
premièrement la négation et la
dénaturation immédiate des faits par
l'état français et son désir de les
cacher 2 la volonté de la gauche
institutionnelle que la mémoire de la
manifestation de charonne compte l'eau
as en février 1962 recouvre celle du
drame
de 1961 3 le souhait des premiers
gouvernements de l'algérie indépendante
plus tard de voir passer sous silence
une mobilisation organisée par des
responsables du fln devenus pour la
plupart des opposants au nouveau régime
ce drame comme beaucoup d'autres
monte dans quel abîme de cruauté de
lâcheté ou d' aveuglement volontaire ou
pas le racisme la dépression et la
guerre font sombrer les nations rares
sont les héros est souvent tardivement
reconnu est trop facilement oublier les
victimes obscures les premiers clips
d'indignation après le 17 octobre neuf
ans d'ailleurs pas des partis mais des
intellectuels des étudiants des
syndicats et des associations de gauche
le 18 octobre donc le lendemain de cette
féroce répression les temps modernes la
revue dirigée par jean paul sartre à
l'époque lance un appel signé par 229
intellectuels réunis en moins d'une
semaine dont robert antelme déportait ex
déportés simple pierre vidal naquet qui
a perdu sa famille qui avait perdu sa
famille à auschwitz les clivages à
triolet sont du nombre
les 23 et 30 octobre des professeurs
lise enchères une déclaration sur le
racisme
avant de commencer leur cours le 30
octobre un communiqué des unions
départementales cgt cftc et fo de la
seine et du bureau de lunettes
protestent contre les discriminations
visant les travailleurs étrangers
algérien pardon malgré son ampli
colonialisme
le parti communiste français de l'époque
ne soutenait pas le mot d'ordre
d'indépendance de l'algérie d'où la
relative timidité de ses protestations
contre le couvre-feu comme de celle
d'ailleurs des autres grandes parties de
gauche au lendemain du 17 octobre
shahrani le lendemain du 17 octobre bien
que l'une des principales tuerie soit se
soit passé sous les fenêtres de
l'humanité du journal l'humanité
ce journal titré en une sur l'ouverture
du congrès du parti communiste de
l'union soviétique et on mettait de
publier leur apporter aux écouteurs à un
peu de silence quand même
depuis juillet le reportage pourtant
accablant de son photographe georges
attache ta fait en grande partie du
balcon du siège du journal
aujourd'hui justice est presque fait la
déclaration du président de la
république et drass que le travail de
mémoire dus aux descendants des victimes
soient dûment accompli et la proposition
de résolution présentée aujourd'hui par
le groupe clc répond légitimement à ce
que je crois être la préoccupation de
tous les républicains
reste maintenant à exhumer enfin dans sa
complexe épaisseur la vérité historique
nous ne savons pas encore le nombre
exact des morts et des blessés
pour cela le groupe écologiste demande
plus que l'érection d'un lieu de même
mois ils demandent l'ouverture sans et
fiction des archives publiques encore
disponibles ou qui n'ont pas été
détruites comme celle de de l'hôpital de
nanterre ou encore ou expurgé comme
celle de la de la police ainsi que la
fin de l'octroi de dérogations au compte
gouttes
seul le travail des historiens nous
permettra d'échapper aux à peu près et
aux contestations indigne cette tâche-là
et celles non des parlementaires mais
des chercheurs notre devoir à nous ici
et d'exiger que le 17 octobre 1961
trouve sa juste place dans l'histoire de
notre pays une histoire qui comme toute
histoire compte des pages sombres
à côté de ces pages glorieuses le groupe
écologiste auteur lui même d'une ppl
similaire votera le texte de nos
collègues du crc merci merci madame
esther benbassa dans la suite du débat
la parole est à madame la présidente
bariza khiari
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues le 17
octobre 61 il y à 51 ans
de nombreux algériens répondait à
l'appel de la fédération de france du
front de libération nationale invitant à
manifester pour protester non seulement
contre la guerre mais aussi contre un
couvre-feu discriminatoire qui ne
touchait que ce que l'on appelait alors
les français musulmans
ce rassemblement était pacifique mais il
s'agissait aussi de montrer la
détermination des manifestants à ne pas
subir de mesures discriminatoires au
faciès est aussi à mettre fin au
colonialisme en algérie le colonialisme
qu'on me disait aimé césaire cette
aliénation
à l'époque on est brave est pas
impunément l'autorité de l'état
emprisonnement et intimidations serait à
l'évidence de la partie personne
n'imagine cependant le déchaînement de
violence qui aurait lieu devant des
effectifs qui grossissait d'heure en
heure les policiers firent preuve sur
instruction du préfet d'alors un certain
maurice papon de sinistre mémoire d'une
violence peu commune
certains membres des forces de l'ordre
veer dans cette soirée l'occasion de
pouvoir régler de vieilles querelles
sans crainte de poursuites
la police autorise à le recours aux
ratonnades desserrant le mort à certains
de ses éléments les plus dangereux
ce jour-là une répression sanglante
d'une violence et d'une sauvagerie
inouïe se déclencha arrestations
massives noyade tortures et déportations
frappes font aveuglément les algériens
de paris et de sa banlieue
certains manifestants furent tués sur
place d'autres internés et certains
disparu dans des conditions mystérieuses
les jours suivants on fit de macabre
découverte de nombreux corps flottant à
la surface de la seine jusqu'au havre
aujourd'hui encore il est difficile de
connaître précisément le nombre de
victimes
ce qui est sûr et certain c'est que le
chiffre officiel
avancée par le préfet papon est très
très loin de la réalité
nombre de familles etc sans nouvelles
d'un père d'un frère d'un oncle d'un
mari d'un grand père d'un fils les
autorités opérer une rétention
d'information bien réelles tandis que
les proches nous est pas non plus se
montrer trop curieux de peur de
représailles
certains sont ainsi demeurés avec des
questions pour le restant de leur vie
en l'absence de tout corps de toute
information de toute reconnaissance
il n'y a rien de pire qu ignorer la
situation d'un proche il n'y a rien de
pire que de pressentir le malheur sans
pouvoir s'en assurer le travail de deuil
est toujours plus difficile c'est encore
sans preuve sans la certitude que la
personne a bien disparu
ce silence l'état le gardera 51 ans
police justice pouvoirs publics de
gauche comme de droite ne regarde pas
sur cet événement drapant d'un voile
d'ombré d'oubli cette nuit ce sordide où
s'est joué le drame
les archives fürth inaccessible elles le
sont d'ailleurs encore permettant ainsi
l'existence d'un tel écart entre les
différentes estimations du victime un
masque malsain recouvrait le visage que
pris la république ce soir-là autorisant
mensonges et dénis les autorités
semblaient avoir apposé le sceau de
l'oubli éternelle sur cette terrible
nuit où l'on assassinats dans les rues
et sur les ponts de france
de fait il a fallu le procès de maurice
papon relatives à la déportation des
juifs de gironde pour que rejaillissent
cette vérité que l'on avait voulu
occulter pour que revienne le débat que
l'on avait souhaité terre pour que la
lumière se fasse sur des événements
qu'on avait espéré dans les ténèbres
pour longtemps il faut ici remercier la
ténacité d'une poignée de journalistes
et d'historiens qui par leur travail et
leur souci de la vérité ont tenté
d'obtenir témoignages et preuves des
événements survenus ce patient est
ingrat travail de collecte et de
recoupage d'information commence à
produire ses fruits permettant de faire
entrer une lumière scène sur ses tâches
de l'histoire nationale c'est à ces
quelques personnes
dara courage que l'on doit aujourd'hui
une meilleure appréciation des faits
certains d'entre eux n'hésitent pas à
rappeler au préfet papon ses états de
service à l'époque de son procès depuis
les juifs déportés aux a jusqu aux
arabes jeté dans la seine
ne craignant ni les intimidations ni les
menaces puisque un procès en diffamation
leur fut intenté il portait à la
connaissance du public leur travail
je tiens à ce stade de mon intervention
a salué leur courage salué leur travail
et celui des associations collectifs
pour la reconnaissance du 17 octobre
je voudrais ici évoqué la mémoire de
mouloud aounit président du mrap passer
sur l'autre rive
comme pour ne pas nous déranger une
belle journée d'août alors que vivent
ils ont dérangé beaucoup pour le travail
qui n'a cessé de faire pour la
reconnaissance de cette tragédie il
déclarait notamment
je le cite nous voulons la
reconnaissance de ces faits ne voulons
pas culpabiliser l'ensemble du peuple
français mais nous voulons empêcher
l'oubli et construire une mémoire
solidaire qui puisse fonder aujourd'hui
une convivialité entre le peuple
français et le peuple algérien cette
commémoration n'est pas pour nous un
vague récit d'un passé douloureux mais
un acte de mémoire présent indispensable
pour construire un vivre ensemble car
l'oubli structure les logiques de
revanche et participe à la production
des discriminations
on sait combien il reste deux ressorts
inconscient comme si cette période
période noire n'était toujours pas fini
c'est à ce type d'engagement
d'associations que l'on doit notamment
la première reconnaissance officielle du
17 octobre par le maire de paris
bertrand delanoë le maire de paris a eu
le premier le courage d'apposer une
plaque commémorative le 17 octobre 2001
pour rappeler la mémoire des disparus
préférant dans un texte sobre préférant
un texte sobre aux polémiques de
certains depuis près d'une centaine de
maires de france ont suivi ce bel
exemple le 17 octobre 2012
le combat a finalement abouti 51 ans
après cette féministe funeste nuit la
république au travers du chef de
et un et al'inverse de ses prédécesseurs
a reconnu la réalité des faits et la
sanglante répression qui avait eu lieu
lors de ces manifestations
ces mots tout simples pense pour partie
les plis de l'histoire et la douleur
qu'elle occasionne je tiens à remercier
le groupe crc pour avoir inscrit dans la
survie dans l'agenda législatif
l'engagement du candidat françois
hollande de reconnaître publiquement la
responsabilité de la république dans
cette répression sanglante
l'adoption de cette proposition de
résolution sur un geste de concorde à
l'adresse du peuple algérien ce débat
est d'autant plus salutaire qu'il permet
d'effectuer certaines mises aux points
face à un conflit dont les stigmates
sont encore prégnante dans certaines
couches de la société française à une
guerre qui longtemps n'a pas dit son nom
à une histoire qui de tous bords à les
difficultés à passer le président
françois hollande à désirer placé son
mandat sous le signe de l'apaisement et
la reconnaissance
certains esprits chagrins avides de
polémique de bas étage ont voulu y voir
les signes d'un abaissement d'un retour
à la sempiternelle repentance laquelle
repentance n'a été réclamée par aucun de
ceux qui demandent la reconnaissance des
faits et n'est mise en avant que par
ceux qui veulent faire acte de diversion
face au nécessaire travail courageux que
nous avons tous à faire par ailleurs il
est tout de même étrange que ceux qui
aujourd'hui se pare du noble vêtements
de l'indignation ne trouvait rien à
redire aux déclarations de jacques
chirac lorsqu'il admettait la
participation de l'été de l'état et sa
responsabilité dans la rafle du vel
d'hiv concédé considérait-il alors que
l'état de la république s'abaissant
s'abaisser en reconnaissant la réalité
des faits estime est il scandaleux les
propos du président de la république
non seulement je ne le crois pas mais je
pense qu'aujourd'hui encore on les
trouverait près à juste titre d'ailleurs
à défendre les propos du président
jacques chirac
se pourrait-il qu'une vérité une vérité
devienne provocation quand elle est
prononcée par une voix de gauche
il faudrait pourtant comprendre mes
chers collègues que la france et
l'algérie souhaite écrire une nouvelle
page des relations bilatérales
une page épurée des conflits passés or
pour écrire ensemble cette page
autour d'un partenariat stratégique nous
devons être d'accord sur la lecture de
la page précédente
la reconnaissance simple et lucide des
événements du 17 octobre gommera ainsi
pour partie l'abomination du texte sur
les effets positifs de la colonisation
et participera d'une volonté de
construire une nouvelle relation de
bâtir un futur commun sur des bases
saines et accepté de tous ceux qui font
semblant de pousser des cris d'orfraie
aujourd'hui n'ont ils pas compris qu il
en va de l'intérêt de notre pays ne sont
ils pas capables de sortir des schémas
suranné n'ont ils pas cette capacité que
jacques chirac en son temps et françois
hollande aujourd'hui de quitter le
costume de politiciens pour revêtir
l'habit d'homme d'état ce pas en avant
car accompli françois hollande
s'accompagnera sans doute d'une
nécessaire ouverture plus large des
archives afin que les historiens
puissent travailler sur des sources
précises et proposer une lecture
détaillée des événements
un demi siècle après les événements
c'est le bon moment le parlement
n'auront pas dicter l'histoire
interférer dans le travail des
historiens
il souhaite instaurer un débat aucune
guerre n'est propre aucun conflit n'a
les héros d'un côté et les démons de
l'autre la guerre d'algérie n'échappe
pas à cette dure loi
à ce titre jeudi prochain notre collègue
mairie présentera un texte visant à
commémorer l'ensemble des victimes du
conflit algérien sans distinction de
caen et d'engagement la date du 19 mars
a été choisie
non parce qu'elle marquerait d'une
quelconque manière la fin de la guerre
mais parce qu'elle constitue une date
éminemment symbolique celle du
cessez-le-feu
cette date met en avant la volonté des
deux parties d'aboutir à un règlement
pacifique du conflit et à renoncer
durablement l usage de la violence
cela ne signifie pas que la violence où
les hosties hostilités ont disparu après
le 19 mars
puisque les attentats de l'oas les
massacre de harkis sont autant d'actes
témoignant de l'horreur de ce conflit
cette commémoration permettra je
l'espère d'instaurer un espace de
dialogue des mémoires offrant une
lecture apaisé de ces questions beaucoup
reste encore à faire
l'état doit encore reconnaître l'usagé
de la torture en algérie
mais aujourd'hui la gauche a démontré
qu'une autre vision des relations franco
algériennes étaient possibles accès non
sur la repentance mais sur le dialogue
le respect et l'exode et les examens des
erreurs passées nous quittons
l'hémicycle du sénat merci à vous
d'avoir suivi ce débat nous reviendrons
sur cette question de la reconnaissance
du 17 octobre 1961 plus amplement dans
notre ange d'information de 19h et de 22
heures tout de suite à suivre preuve par
trois l'émission politique de la
rédaction de public sénat qui reçoit
aujourd'hui jean vincent placé le
président du groupe écologiste au sénat
bonne soirée à tous